first time we met she propositioned me
she seemed so sure I was sure it was so
shy and mysterious
that's something you'd like to tell me
something you like that from your wife I
know every have you been i amazed at the
reaction so far so far we've been to
Toronto Film Festival and in Venice and
I think we're all just extremely excited
for the film's soon to actually get out
there for for the proper audience but
it's been wonderful to to have the few
screenings and it's been a very very
warm reception from people that I meet
and it's always very humbling because I
think when it comes down to your eye I
love acting and film we're all story
talent so when people seem to enjoy that
means that means the world what did you
love most about your character like
apart from the amazing wardrobe mm-hmm I
want from the amazing book wardrobe I I
think I'd love playing a character that
I was able to look up to I even myself
hat and likes take a step back in my own
kind of emotional spectrum and just
think oh my god would I be able to do
this and I I think I'm a big romantic
deep down so I always admired her
because she is never she's never
considered to be my never felt her week
she's just a person who is so daring in
the sense that she would be able to even
sacrifice a lot from her own around
himself to be able to give the person
that she loves all the support and and
to also dared to have that unconditional
love and see the person that they that
she's with for what she really is we
were talking about that in the office
saying it out of the two of you like we
can get fair to say that girder and
maybe is the strongest one out of the
two like Eddie Redmayne was really brave
and but you were like the support said
you don't get I think it's that thing of
what they both realized is that the
journey that lily has to go to is
inevitable I mean of that the essence of
a person is of course she needs to be
that's not a choice yeah she is Lily
that's the fact whilst gurdas person who
needs to take a decision of of course
I'll be there I'll be the biggest
support and I'll stand by you in
whatever happens and and I think I was
touched by that too to see to see that
kind of of love with always very iconic
and quite a unique and still relatable I
guess you're different from most girls I
feel like need to ask your permission
for history
it's only em it was refreshing to have a
male host earth that was in the makeup
chair longer than you for once surely
and what was your first reaction to
seeing as Eddie Redmayne in his oh well
i was actually at um i was doing my we
were doing screen tests would you do a
few days before we start to shoot
checking all the backgrounds and
different costumes and i walked on such
and I was looking for Eddie and then
this red-haired woman turns around and
I've actually been in Tom just loved
everyone laughs I'd been in the same
room as Eddie five minutes and that was
the first time I saw him in costume as
lily and I i still remember that smile
lily has an extraordinary smile c6 quite
extraordinary and you've got five films
our next year and it's been said that
2016 over the year of alicia vikander
and you never know you might be taken
home in oscar and that one a bit of a
waste of a year what are you its eyes
the most of all next year and you have
any new year's resolutions um I'm really
excited like you searched for I'm
shooting a born right now comes out next
year and two other films called tulip
fever and light between oceans so yeah
that it will be a another very very fun
year to come I think I love you
because you're the only person who made
sense of me
made me possible
you